let's take a look behind the scenes of
John Wick 4. Keanu Reeves didn't train
for three months for nothing the guy is
given NASCAR racing a run for their
money with his 180 drifts and high-speed
chases of course not without a handful
of onset injuries and accidents though
let's get into it this was a major
aspect of his training that definitely
deserves its own highlight I got to do
some more driving and not just any
ordinary driving yeah I'm talking about
some X
ordinary driving driving that you would
never want to do with mom in the car
they took the car stunts to
eight they're more complex now than they
used to be and luckily for Keanu he
really enjoyed it it was really fun to
be in the car again he had to do some
some high speed 180s and 270s but the
hardest scene he had to master was when
he did a reverse 180 and Rift while
reloading his prop Gun and shooting out
the freaking door major props to Keanu
and his stunt team on that one you
should know that after four movies Keanu
Reeves is no one to be messed with the
guy must be made of like steel or
something there's a car food gun food
and now sword food there's lots of
fooling around he's known for doing as
many stunts as possible so obviously he
had to go through some brutal training
in order to get there like the guy
trained for 12 weeks to achieve what
they called the toolbox basically a
toolbox of skills that he could utilize
for the films he literally learned how
to stunt drive like the pros the art of
Judo Jiu Jitsu and how to professionally
wield nunchucks he describes this film
as the most difficult physical role he's
had in his entire career and like the
fact that it took four of these movies
for him to say that is really something
else gun training martial arts training
driving training he saw his first man
there last man to leave our guy was
training five days a week for eight
hours a day and it truly seems like he
was having a great time doing it when
it's time to hit the gym or hit a
specific skill set he's always there
he's always been incredibly involved of
course it also helps that he's been
trained by some of the best stunt
coordinators and performers in the biz
I've never worked with an actor who's
willing to work that hard train that
hard
big guys an animal like I didn't think
it was possible to be more impressed
with Keanu Reeves but here we are
there's a super intense scene where he's
just blasting through guys left and
right and the camera is hovering just
above him yeah that was just multiple
really long takes there weren't a ton of
cuts happening in that moment it was
pretty high pressure but luckily the
cameras were automated so it was a lot
less work for the crew but it didn't
take any weight from keanu's shoulders
he couldn't see the cameras but they did
have certain movements programmed into
them so he had to make sure he was in
sync with every one of them if there was
just one little mistake he had to reset
from the beginning and I don't know
exactly how many takes it took him but
knowing Keanu I would probably be
incredibly impressed with that number
naturally though mistakes were made some
of them hospital-inducing you know there
had to be at least a few injuries on the
set of this movie I'm actually more
surprised at how few there were I made a
mistake once and I cut a gentleman's
head open
ouch okay Brew that's gotta be the worst
of it right well one guy got hit by a
car was in the car he had to go to the
hospital fortunately there weren't any
other major accidents none that were
accounted for in the media anyway but
yeah so that really sucked excuse my
language Donnie Yen put a lot of thought
into the fighting style of Kane it
wasn't even really about the martial
arts for him it was more about his
personality in any of his films he never
really focuses on the style of martial
arts when it comes to developing how his
character fights this guy his family man
introvert calms walk slow talk slow so
that's probably not something we as the
audience would pick up on right but you
can see those personality traits show up
in like every fight scene therefore his
movements is very reserved he only
reacts to an outside force obviously I'm
talking about Keanu Reeves and Lawrence
Fishburne here as you no doubt have
guessed
I am Morpheus like these two are thick
ever since their Matrix days over a
decade ago so it's no surprise that the
set of John Wick is a lot more fun and
lighthearted than you'd think Lawrence's
favorite thing about Keanu is actually
his sense of humor so in between getting
punched in the face Keanu is cracking
jokes and making the whole set laugh he
makes you laugh a lot does he yeah he's
got a great sense of humor you also
might have unknowingly seen them on one
of their bro bonding trips we taking
some nice motorcycle rides not gonna lie
Ashburn described the stunts filmed in
Paris as breathtaking and completely off
the chain it's been everything I've been
wanting to see on screen one thing I
know for sure is that Keanu has many
scenes where he's moving through or
rather fighting through hundreds of
extras this was one of the most tedious
and difficult scenes to capture mostly
due to the fact that they didn't want
anybody getting hurt the setup for these
moments took longer than you could ever
imagine too so yeah let's talk about
that for a sec you know you gotta go on
the playground a little bit how long do
you think it takes to set up a John Wick
fight scene if you guessed days weeks or
even months you'd be right Lawrence
Fishburne says that's one thing he
always forgets until he steps on to set
he says everything happens between the
words action and cut seem like magic but
it's not it's all prep again days weeks
and months worth of it that's always fun
when you can still continually to expand
your own ideas I know I talked a little
bit about the fight scenes and the
carfoo but I need to shout out the stunt
coordinator Scott Rogers who actually
worked worked with Keanu Reeves to give
us the ultimate car chase scene Keanu is
so dedicated to performing his own
stunts that he started training nine
months in advance to hone his driving
skills like can you actually believe it
all that work definitely paid off
because Scott Rogers tailored that scene
specifically to keanu's driving caliber
not the other way around he actually
started getting too good in the car so
as I've already discussed a lot Keanu
Reeves has a major set of skills
although yes a huge part of that was
because of all the long hard hours of
training he did but what makes John Wick
so great is that the stunt
choreographers work with his natural
strengths they already know how he moves
so it eliminates hours and hours of
training him to move in a different way
we kind of watch him and see what he
does best and then we just figure out
okay that movie looks best for him here
even if they don't need that particular
movement if he looks good doing it
they'll incorporate it somewhere else
we're trying to get a ride we're trying
to catch the magic yeah let's talk about
the elephant in the room covid
unfortunately delayed this movie an
entire year not only that but they also
didn't want John Wick to be competing
against top gun Maverick in 2022 at the
box office so they went ahead and pushed
it back another year it was announced in
a teaser trailer that yeah was a little
disappointing to see but Charming enough
to be forgiven that's cool that's kind
so who else was super bummed about the
delays I have no clue but uh you know I
wish everybody luck well through all
these delays I'm still so excited to
watch Keanu Reeves in the car food genre
threw that car around pretty good to see
how many extras heat punches in the face
and of course to watch him share the
screen with his longtime bestie Lawrence
Fishburne they're just such a pleasure
to watch but what are you most excited
to see in John Wick 4.